Japan review
Japan review it's been a year since I
moved to Japan and I thought it made
sense to finally rate Japan I will talk
about things I like and the things I
don't like which seems to be the only
two options available if you have
opinions about this country
so sugoi or did you know Japan is
actually really bad it's got a lot of
survival issues okay I will list one
good thing and bad thing and I will not
hold back there's no trash bins
where I'm gonna put my trash
I have to put in my pocket
oh
there's always these generic things that
you hear or yes when we you visit it's
kind of weird but then you realize it's
not a big deal anyway let's start off
with number one reason I like Japan
it feels like a giant playground no I
don't mean in the Logan Paul kind of
sense of doing whatever the hell you
want
but rather there's a infinite things all
right lazy feels like to explore and
experience and I've been here a year now
and I don't think I'm gonna get bored
anytime soon although I am having a
child so I don't know how much more I
have time to experience
but it really feels like a whole new
world and if you visited you can
probably relate to it and I'm glad that
even a year in it still feels incredibly
fresh and I even would say that you
realize that the best part of Japan
aren't the touristy places kind of
obviously but there are so many areas
that I found that I really enjoy
visiting and this is probably more
specific to me but you know Tokyo is
very busy and so many times I just catch
myself surrounded by what feels like
hundreds of people and they have no idea
who I am
everyone is just doing their own thing
and that feels so [__] good
now once it was staring at me no one's
following me no one's being weird you
guys are weird and I'm just kidding I
just love the feeling of being able to
exist in public and uh not worrying
about what everyone else is doing like
I've said this before but I genuinely
enjoy talking to fans or when people
approach me it always makes me happy but
it can be kind of frustrating to always
wanting to just do your own thing and
always be
you know so yeah let's move on to the
bad things of Japan number one reason
Japan is bad it's kind of a heavy
subject and I haven't seen anyone else
really talk about it it's not brought up
very often at least and that is cones
there's too many cones in Japan once you
see it you cannot unsee it they're
everywhere they say oh Japan has so many
vending machines there's like five per
one person no the opposite
there's more cones than people why are
there so many cones I need to know we
got the tall ones we got the small ones
we got the funny ones the cute ones the
sexy ones I do like those I just don't
understand that whoever plays these
cones think I'm just gonna barge through
oh thank God there's cones here
otherwise I had no idea what I was gonna
and I realized the cone history of Japan
stretches centuries okay if you played
Animal Crossing sometimes it's a
Japanese game so sometimes you get these
items right you're like oh that's kind
of weird I don't know exactly what that
is but it's probably something Japanese
and then you get the bamboo thing and
you're like what the hell is that what
am I even gonna do with that and then
you see it in real life here in Japan
you're like holy [__] it's a cone that's
a cone they're everywhere
I feel like they are following me
I'm glad I was able to talk about this
I'm for one and willing to call out
Japan knock it off man no more cones
there's enough cones let me tell you
something even better than cones you may
have noticed new merch finally it's been
forever my mom came over she had
unofficial merge because I literally
have no other merch I've hadn't hadn't
merch I'm sorry Mom so we spruced up the
logo got a cool back design the team
that worked on it really truly
understand how my brand and I think they
did such a good job these pieces look
amazing and I think you guys are gonna
really like them as well these are
available for limited time only so make
sure you order now so excited to finally
have this merch available thanks to
amaze for making this happen we are
gonna have one piece that will stay on
the store so my mom will not buy the
wrong merch but for a limited time that
piece will be available in this color
off-white kind of color it looks really
nice and then after that you can still
get it but not in this color that's
you want this one yeah I get it
so yeah check that out if you're
interested I'm so happy about these
designs and I hope you guys would like
them as well all right reason number two
I like Japan yay when we first announced
that we were gonna move to Japan there
was so many people just saying how bad
Japan is actually did you know Japan is
really bad did you know this I have to
list all these reasons now because
everyone is like thing and then thing
Japan ah so I have to tell them and I
it's actually but one thing in
particular that people said was that old
people really don't like foreigners they
hate them so when I was gonna stop by to
say hi to our neighbors who was a little
older at least some of them I was
terrifying I heard all these stories you
know like what are they gonna do to us
so I had my guard up ready for the worst
and I was met with nothing but kindness
and welcoming and I felt like a total
dick for having this preconceived ideas
thanks to other people
and just a side comment like yes there
are definitely probably people that
don't like foreigners and all that stuff
but I realized I should let my own
experience is dictate how I feel about
certain things maybe that's just
ignoring a problem I don't know it just
feels like it's a bad way to approach
life if you always have a negative
expectation you know it's smiling people
may Smile Back
smiled back
thank you sometimes they don't and
that's okay you know anyway my point
being Japanese people are very in my own
experience
are very nice and friendly the majority
at least and yes even to foreigners I
feel like they are especially nice to
foreigners because they think we're like
a kid lost at Disneyland or something
I just asked for directions I didn't
need you to walk me for half an hour to
this specific place I was going but
thank you I appreciate it a lot of times
I go bouldering alone and there's always
other groups of people being supportive
and yelling like I'm about there like go
you can do it I love it I think it's
great you know or if you're small
talking with people people generally
want to communicate with you and I love
having those moments but of course
there's times where people are like oh
you're a foreigner I don't feel like
even trying
which again it's fine speaking of which
reason I don't like Japan number two
their language
I have lived here for a year and I'm not
fluent in Japanese
I am dumb I am very dumb I remember the
moment we moved here I had studied some
Japanese and I was like
Let's test out this knowledge that I
have acquired let's go I'm just gonna
come in it's gonna be dangerous and you
enter a store for the first time and
they're like
what
what oh
what the classic the most common
experiences that you have aren't
necessarily what you're taught in the
textbook yay I know I think that's the
same for anyone learning a language for
the first time but don't even get me
started on the kanji main what the [__]
is this I feel like Japanese is such a
hard language obviously but I don't
think people realize how hard it is at
least me personally because the more you
learn the more you realize you don't
know [__]
for English speakers Japanese is
considered one of the most difficult
languages and because it's just so
different I listed it as bad because
that was my first kind of experience
with it coming here but the more I
interact with people the more it feels
like I'm unlocking new skills you know
oh I made a phone call for the first
time oh I could ask someone over the
phone I know big deal but it's like oh I
can actually do that or even just having
a small tiny yes shittiest conversation
with a stranger it's still something and
it feels good you start to all of a
sudden understand you know a movie if
you're watching oh I understand actually
what's going on here or I can play games
and kind of get what this they're saying
I have to look up words obviously but to
me all those new experiences that it
unlocks to me is very rewarding even
though it's such a challenge I would
actually now say it's a good thing I
played it on its head it was a good
thing all along but I obviously have a
long [__] way to go
and it just I don't think it will damage
time reason number three I like Japan
this is nothing to do with Japan to say
it's more related to me taking a more
relaxed approach to YouTube for my
entire 20s I did nothing but YouTube
that was my life and that's okay but I
also think it was a little toxic
probably you know if I wasn't making
videos I sure as hell was thinking about
making videos I uploaded videos during
our honeymoon
and it feels really good to finally be
free from it you know and I can discover
other things in life there are other
things in life
a new hobbies and interest that I've
always wanted to do I can do and have so
much fun with it surfing I know I would
love for the longest time and I finally
get to do it and it's so [__] amazing
I love learning new things anything that
isn't necessarily connected to all of
this on the internet and that is
something I'm very very grateful that I
discovered so yeah it's not really Japan
I could have done that anywhere but it's
largely why I enjoyed so much here
reason I don't like Japan number three
this is probably the most trickiest one
and it's the rules what are the rules
Japan has so many rules and it's a bit
conflicting for me to complain about
because a lot of the best stuff about
Japan not the best stuff but a lot of
the reasons why Japan works so well is
because of the rules you know the trains
are always on time things just work in
general it's hard to explain the streets
are clean people aren't loud in public
and so on and these are sort of societal
rules that make it happen more or less
but sometimes There are rules that just
don't make any sense and I have no
problem following rules as long as I
understand the reason for it you know
don't talk on the phone on the train
because it's generally annoying when
other people do that to you A lot of it
is just be thoughtful of other people
it's not just about you and that just
makes it more pleasant for everyone but
one rule is especially which I talked
about before is the fact that because of
kovid I'm not allowed to be in the
delivery room for our baby for more than
two hours that's because of covered
rules it just doesn't make sense to me
and I tell people about this like uh
family and friends and they're always
like well why don't you just ask them or
like why don't you talk to them I'm sure
you can there's got to be somewhere and
it's like no it's Japan okay there are
rules and people follow the rules for
better or worse you know so the more I
time I spend here the more time I
encounter these sort of rules that in my
head at least don't make sense and I
don't want to make it seem like like I'm
above it or like oh I don't get it so
therefore I'm above it but it's still
really frustrating I think because yeah
rule six is for a reason and even though
the reason it might not be obvious to
you they are usually there for some sort
of practicality I don't know I'm just
trying I don't get it man
so lastly the reason I like Japan I feel
like there should be a word for it it's
more of a feeling than anything and it's
could be happening at any point during
the day maybe um riding a bicycle it's
sunny outside and surrounded by trees
and it's just Pleasant in general a warm
wind hits your face and you just sort of
have that moment where it feels just so
amazing it feels like you're living a
dream it could be just walking my dogs
and then out in the distance everything
is clear and you see Mount Fuji popping
out you know I'm surfing and the Sun is
setting and it's turning the whole ocean
to look pink and it's just one of those
moments where you feel like I'm living
in a dream I just feel like how is this
real I I don't even believe in myself
and I catch myself a lot in those kind
of moments living here and it's just a
wonderful thing
happy days
it's actually really silly talking about
him because it's not like these things
don't exist anywhere for anyone it's not
like oh Japan ah but moving here I feel
like I definitely get those moments more
often it's not like I wasn't happy in UK
or wherever but I think just in general
it has changed me and my priorities and
as a person to the better in a weird way
and I realize a lot of it is also very
specific to me and my circumstance I
have the opportunity to not work as much
anymore and I have the opportunity to
have a lot of freedom and not engage in
a lot of the bad parts of the tough work
ethic in Japan for example and so I
think me specifically feeling like I
don't get recognized so that's also a
reason I really enjoy here a lot of the
reasons I enjoy Japan is very specific
to me at least and people like Japan for
different reasons obviously I'm not
surprised or necessarily think people
are wrong to trying to dispatch around
Japan to from being this holy Mecca or
anything like that but I think
ultimately it's an amazing place to
visit you should definitely do it but I
also think not everyone's gonna enjoy
living here that's my big Asterix
basically I feel like if you're content
as a person you should be able to be
happy where you live I at least for me
for example living in UK I was just as
happy as well but like I said catch
myself in these happy moments more often
here which I'm very grateful for so yeah
I hope that sort of summarizes it I
would put Japan s here thank you for
watching this video I see you guys next
time